est-ce que vous vous souvenez de ce que
vous faisiez en février 2022 moi je me
souviens bien je faisais un burnout et
ben figurez-vous qu'aujourd'hui dans le
cadre de ma série de vidéo sur la santé
mentale c'est justement de ça dont je
vais vous parler le burnout ça tombe
bien enfin ça tombe bien non ça tombe
jamais bien justement c'est même pour ça
que c'est important d'en
[Musique]
parler le burnout c'est un petit peu
comme la trigonométrie les fonctions
affines ou le vol au vent tout le monde
connaît le nom mais on sait pas
forcément ce que c'est en vrai et comme
c'est important de savoir pour être
capable de repérer les premiers signes
et donc d'agir avant que ça nous arrive
vraiment et ben on va faire un petit
tour de la question le burnout ça existe
depuis quand alors à l'origine le mot
burnout il désignait l'épuisement
professionnel du personnel de santé ce
serait un psychanalyste allemand
installé à New York du nom de Herbert
freedenberger qui aurait employé le
terme pour la première fois en 1971 donc
vous voyez ça fait pas si longtemps
attention ça veut pas dire que ça
existait pas avant on parlait déjà
d'épuisement professionnel à la fin des
des années 50 mais ça veut dire qu'à ce
moment-là c'était devenu suffisamment un
vrai truc ça avait déjà été suffisamment
identifié pour qu'on lui donne un nom et
ensuite le phénomène bah il a continué à
s'emplifier avec les changements de mode
de vie et les gros bouleversements dans
le monde du travail et ça a fini par
toucher un peu tout le monde le burnout
c'est quoi exactement le problème c'est
que c'est pas si clair d'abord parce que
le burnout c'est un syndrome
c'est-à-dire que ça touche plein de truc
ça fait appel à plein de notions donc
c'est assez complexe ensuite parce que à
force le mot il a fini par être employé
pour désigner plein de situations qui
sont pas vraiment la même chose quoi
j'ai j'ai fait un bernout de malade
mental hier donc déjà vous avez compris
le burnout c'est lié au travail c'est de
là que ça part si vous vous écroulez
complètement après une rupture amoureuse
ou un passage un peu difficile dans
votre vie personnelle c'est pas un
burnout ça veut pas dire que c'est plus
grave ou moins grave juste c'est pas la
même chose et je dis ça c'est pas pour
le plaisir de jouer sur les mots c'est
juste que ça se soigne pas de la même
façon selon ce que c'est ah oui mais
qu'est-ce que c'est justement calme-toi
si on prend la définition mission de la
Haute Autorité de la santé le burnout
c'est un épuisement physique émotionnel
et mental qui résulte d'un
investissement prolongé dans des
situations de travail exigeantes sur le
plan émotionnel bon alors ça pose les
bases he mais quand tu as dit ça tu as
pas tout dit le burnout comment ça
marche le burnout c'est pas juste du
surmenage c'est pas juste avoir trop de
boulot et plus réussir à s'en sortir il
y a de ça bien sûr mais c'est plus que
ça il y a aussi une notion de
frustration et de démotivation globale
face à son travail il y a une sorte de
perte de sens au niveau professionnel
donc oui bien sûr c'est une histoire de
condition de travail l'ambiance qui est
pas forcément bonne la charge de travail
qui peut être trop élevé avec des
objectifs qui sont pas atteignables la
reconnaissance et la considération qu'on
a ou qu'on a pas justement tout ça ça
joue ça joue même beaucoup évidemment
mais ça a aussi à voir avec la façon
dont notre propre rapport à notre
travail a évolué au fil des mois ou des
années et quand il y a cette perte de
sens c'est là que ça vient bien
compliqué on sait plus trop pourquoi on
fait ce qu'on fait on peut trouver ça
complètement inutile par exemple et vu
qu'on y passe beaucoup de temps et qu'on
y consacre quand même beaucoup d'énergie
bah par rebond on finit par se dénigrer
soi-même aussi et là on tombe dans
l'autod dépréciation mon boulot est nul
c'est de la merde moi j'y consacre ma
vie donc mais moi aussi je suis une
merde et au final le résultat c'est que
le stress qui est créé par tous ces
éléments additionnés là et ben ça fait
qu'on finit par plus réussir à avancer
on n'arrive plus à faire les choses
comme avant professionnellement avec le
même rythme avec la même efficacité
voire carrément on n'arrive plus à les
faire du tout et puis surtout on finit
par sombrer on sombre physiquement déjà
avec des risques plus élevés de
développer certains problèmes de santé
on sombre psychologiquement aussi avec
là encore le risque que ça dégénère en
maladie comme la dépression par exemple
ou en trouble du comportement
alimentaire ou en addiction et cetera et
cetera et puis ça finit aussi par avoir
des répercussions sur notre vie sociale
comment sa qu'on fait un burnout alors
comme d'habitude c'est mieux de le
prévenir parce que c'est quand même plus
facile que de le guérir et puis bon si
on peut s'éviter de morfler autant y
aller donc la première chose à faire
c'est de savoir repérer les premiers
signes qu'on est peut-être en train de
faire un burnout oui parce que
contrairement à ce qu'on pense on
s'écroule pas comme ça forcément tout
d'un coup ça peut s'installer
progressivement et dans tous les cas
avant d'en arriver au point critique il
se passe des choses donc les signes à
guêter c'est la fatigue déjà elle
s'installe progressivement et elle finit
par se transformer en véritable
épuisement physique émotionnel et mental
et c'est impossible de récupérer même en
se reposant une baisse d'efficacité au
travail on narrive pas à se concentrer à
cause du stress notre mémoire c'est pas
ça non plus on se sent très très vite
débordé et du coup on n'arrive plus à
faire ce qu'on faisait avant la
démotivation on y est plus du tout on a
plus du tout envie d'être là et
progressivement on devient très négatif
très critique voire très cynique sur
tout ce qui concerne le travail et petit
à petit ça devient un mood ça finit par
gagner tout le reste ça finit par gagner
le le perso par exemple et le risque
c'est de finir par s'isoler socialement
l'anxiété on n'est pas tranquille on est
jamais serein on est on est un peu
inquiet on est anxieux quoi au début
c'est juste quand on est au boulot et
quand on rentre à la maison ça va mieux
et puis au bout d'un moment ça finit par
être tout le temps ça se généralise des
troubles du sommeil alors ça c'est lié
au stress et à l'anxiété c'est un grand
classique quand on dort mal et qu'on
sait pas pourquoi c'est qu'il y a
quelque chose qui va pas des troubles de
l'humeur là encore c'est un classique he
vous êtes stressé vous dormez mal et
vous finissez par devenir hritable
d'abord au travail et puis aussi dans
votre vie perso vous avez compris et
puis bien sûr il y a aussi des signes
physiques qui varient d'une personne à
l'autre mot de ventre mot de tête mal de
dos aussi beaucoup et làppeil au départ
ça se manifeste le matin avant de partir
au boulot et puis bah toute la journée
de boulot et puis ça finit par être tout
le temps alors ok vous allez peut-être
vous dire que tout ça c'est pas très
spécifique mais bon vous allez quand
même sentir qu'il y a quelque chose qui
va pas donc dans ces cas-là le truc le
plus important et écoutez bien parce que
vraiment c'est le truc truc le plus
important je viens de le dire parlez-en
parlez-en à quelqu'un parlez-en à
n'importe qui mais parlez-en quelqu'un
qui est proche de vous quelqu'un dont
vous savez que ça va être un bon soutien
quelqu'un à la médecine du travail votre
médecin traitant votre psy si vous en
avez évidemment peu importe l'important
c'est de poser le sujet sur la table
avec quelqu'un qui va ne serait-ce que
vous aider à identifier le problème ça
c'est la base c'est le truc
indispensable pour qu'il se passe
quelque chose après et puis après du
coup bah oui vous allez être guidé vous
allez être orienté vers les personnes
qui vont prendre en charge le burnout ça
soigne oui le burnout ça se soigne comme
d'habitude dans ces cas-là il faut se
faire accompagner bien sûr on en parle à
quelqu'un puis on est orienté vers la
personne la mieux placée pour nous aider
si c'est pas cette personne là et puis
surtout surtout ce qu'il faut bien se
mettre en tête c'est que couper tout
prendre du repos ça va pas suffire il
faut le faire bien sûr ça va vous aider
à vous sentir mieux ça c'est évident
mais si après vous retrouvez la même
chose qu'avant même cause même
conséquence ça va recommencer
ahit
donc pour éviter ça et ben il faut faire
des vrais changements profond déjà il
faut identifier ce qui va pas ce qui est
extérieur à nous hein et puis va voir si
on peut faire en sorte de plus y être
confronté mais aussi de façon plus
individuelle plus personnelle retrouver
du sens alors soit dans ce qu'on faisait
avant soit peut-être dans autre chose ça
peut être le moment d'envisager un
changement aussi he c'est pas
obligatoire mais ça peut être une
possibilité mais dans un premier temps
il va déjà falloir retrouver de l'estime
de soi parce que dans ces cas-là l'image
qu'on a de nous-même
on a pris un sacré cou donc ça ça se
travaille avec une pro ou avec un pro
hein déjà mais on peut faire des trucs
aussi nous-même pour se remettre un peu
sur pied par exemple en trouvant des
activités dans lesquelles on retrouve la
notion de plaisir à faire les choses des
choses qui ont de la valeur à nos yeux
et qui nous aident aussi à nous
valoriser nous-mêmes donc pas de
fatalisme en cas de Burnout il y a des
choses à faire c'est du cas par cas ça
dépend des situations ça dépend des gens
mais il y a des choses à faire et puis
avant de vous laisser là on a parlé de
Burnout mais il y a deux règles d'or et
ça c'est valable pour tout ces règles
d'or c'est premièrement écoutez-vous si
vous voulez pas vous perdre en cours de
route soyez attentif au signaux que vous
vous envoyez à vous-même ça vous
permettra de repérer les trucs qui vont
pas le plus tôt possible et ça c'est
toujours mieux et puis deuxièmement
quand vous sentez qu'il y a quelque
chose qui va pas parlez-en c'est le
premier pas indispensable ça résout pas
tout mais si vous commencez pas par ça
vous résoudrez rien voilà DTC c'est fini
pour aujourd'hui on se retrouve très
vite pour de nouvelles vidéos d'ici là
prenez soin de vous et prenez soin des
autres mettez-vous bien et surtout
portez-vous
[Musique]
bien